[Music]
[Music]
jack reacher has deceased a tight army
bronze star silver star and a purple
heart when god's name is a guy like that
doing a margrave what's a guy like that
doing in jail zip ties
cuffs didn't fit him you guys recycle
seven bodies since you set foot in my
town
i was arrested for murder now you want
my help i want you to do what i say you
just go wherever you want whenever you
want everyone's always jealous i want to
uncover this whole operation
and burn it to the ground
you boys know what's about to happen to
you you leave now
[Music]
i don't go getting yourself arrested for
murder
shooter with someone who knows firearms
well nightmare bullets were 95 grain
that's subsonic this wasn't a first
timer these people are connected and
stone cold killers
so be smart don't break the law and
promise me you won't end up in another
holding cell
no
yeah you got it looking for payback
payback justice vengeance
you're going to kill a whole lot of
people aren't you already started
[Music]
you're about to get your ass kicked no
i'm just going to break the hands of
three drunk kids there's four of us one
of you's got to drive to the hospital
[Music]
it's not a twist off
show off
[Music]
you